like we were talking uh  when you when you first got here i feel  like  this record is kind of like a reminder  oh go ahead and handle your phone  damn i'm in the middle of the interview  mom's on the phone there we go  number one i'm number one on the radio  right now number one i'm in the middle  tell them you tell them how proud listen  tell them how proud you is to me  ted are we on the radio right now tell  them how to put on speaker phone you'll  put a speaker  uh we all like we're  shout out to mom's how's she feeling now  that you know uh you're you're home and  and things are going  in the right direction for you man you  know i'm saying that's mom dudes man  shout out to mom dude  she stayed excited huh she stayed there  that's dope that you your mom's  you've been in the game for two like a  long ass time mom still getting excited  trying to turn radios on that i like  that  come on it's a family thing